it's an event that started back in 2018
in a warehouse and it has grown over the
years into the hottest r b party in town
now at a new location and here to tell
us more is the founder of SimCity Jay
esguerra his partner and co-host Rylan
Kelly and the owner of Leverage
welcome you guys I'm so glad to have you
and talk about this cool concept that
you guys came up with it's called
SimCity tell us a little bit about it
you know I like to go well SimCity is it
is what it is the hottest r b party in
Las Vegas something that we came up with
you know probably four years ago we used
to throw Little House parties and now we
kind of transformed it into like a whole
culture you know so we love r b we grew
up on it it's all we listened to so we
wanted to give it out to the city and
kind of create our own little wave you
know I mean you hear a lot of EDM you
hear a lot of hip-hop but you never
really hear r b on the Strip oh I love
this concept this is like my kind of
music too give me give me each of you
like your top top three r b artists who
Do You Love uh Jagged Edge Chris Brown
Kevin Campbell Usher Chris Brown
now you guys you guys are in a new venue
tell us a little bit about where you're
going to be now
it's dress I mean since I was younger
you know dredge was always the most
popping club to go to especially for
hip-hop and um just like you know
hip-hop and R B kind of being coerced
into you know kind of the same genre
it's just like dope for us as you know
young
um people from Vegas to finally get into
a nightclub and make something happen I
love that now tell us about some of the
artists that have been a part of SimCity
before so you might have heard of some
of them
um one Bryson tiller Keyshia Cole
there's just so many that you know we
still want to tap into but for those
just we named
okay
I'm gonna test you guys come and talk to
me temco
you guys sound good too okay
um
I'm really excited about this you guys
um how do we get tickets how do you be a
part of this so if you go to uh
Instagram you go to SimCity LV you'll
see the ticket Link in our bio and
you'll go to the tickets right there
right now tickets are going for 25 easy
steel you're going for you and your girl
pop out for a good night it's gonna be
awesome thank you guys so much and yeah
get your ticket